I got to ask, because you grew up in France and moving,
you know about, you know, how much,
well you were telling us earlier about how much more we can get paid,
doing the same job being in France and all of us also having,
let's say less work hours as well.
What made you decide to give that up and moved to Japan?
Um, have like a, when I turn my, you,
my story of my internship, uh, uh, to my friends,
I can,
do you really want to go to Japan or maybe shoe because me, I don't want,
I want to, I want to have a life. I, I could completely understand, you know,
there is no, this is the right way and not, so you have,
uh, everybody had, uh, his way of doing it.
And in my case,
I wanted to work in Japanese animation industry because
I like animation. I like manga. Uh, and, uh,
yes, there is some Singh, cocaine and D a bit, sorry. Muds are cheesed
that's. Yeah, but, uh, yeah, it's, uh,
the way to learn also, this is kind of.
It's just purely passion driven.
It just sounds like you are doing it purely for the past.
I was going to say for that pay, you better be passionate.
But, uh, yes, but I mean, any mission, the two or three years are hard.
So if you want to do a career in Japan,
so you have to speak Japanese, you, you can, uh,
manage to work in Japan with English, but, uh,
just as some few study, we open the doors because they have a translator or not.
And, but if you can speak Japanese more open doors we offer.
Right. And as we've established, like, you know, from your stories is that,
you know, getting to know the people as well, it just takes you so far.
It really does seem that like, if you do speak Japanese,
it's like way easier to get into the anime industry than I hate people,
make it out to be, it's definitely an easy mode. Isn't it? I mean, it's,
it's the same moving to any country and turning their industry. Right.
I think you almost find it.
People put like the anime industry on like a pedestal, right? It's like,
it's the anime industry. It's mythical, it's Japanese.
We don't know what happens. Right. But then when you talk to people, it's like,
oh yeah, I got paid like two years of frame. It's.
Like going back to the.
The, the story of the guy who, you know,
came up and said like that he wanted to work at trigger.
Guarantee. He has no idea what it's like to actually work in.
True. It's like, it's like six o'clock. He's like ready to go home.
And everyone's like, no, no, there's four more hours.
Yes. In Japan you have a Dango and uh, you saw,
you can just say, oh, you can leave the study at eight, but no,
exactly, exactly.
You can leave at eight and then you'd see nobody leaves leaving at the clock-out
times in Japanese companies. This is not an official clock-out time.
It's like a suggested yeah. All the time. But.
Yeah. So, so when I was, uh, walking in graffiti camp,
and first I, in my mind, I say,
one year we see how one year will be too hard or
we'd go back to France and yeah. Faster one year.
And okay. My sink, I couldn't do a one plus one like that. When you,
when you have on the yard and no, it's, I'm,
I'm at my five years and yes, I, he, his tutor. I,
yeah, I know. I have found a good study or foresee. Um, I learn a lot of,
from my same pies and yeah, I, uh, I can do more, more.
How much longer do you think though? Because you, you.
Said you were 31, right? Yeah. Still doing all night.
Uh, yeah. It's lunchtime, but you can not do that. Yeah.
I was going to say, cause like, I've just hit my thirties as well. And man,
all nighters, they are deaf. They definitely hit different your body.
[inaudible] because when you're 20, you a few cans of red bull,
it's easy, 48 hours.
It was younger getting your drink at night and you go to work does a day. Yeah,
it was okay. No.
No. It was like 11:00 PM.
Definitely do find that my willpower is over exerting my body. I'm like, no,
I can do this diet.
Yeah. So you have to push yourself. And like I said, um,
so it's a lot of hours you are sitting. And sometime I was,
I don't think there were,
because I had a lot of pain in my feet because of her was because
I was always sitting, sitting. And so the amount of, uh,
water, water, blood on my ankle was swollen.
God. So that's what happens.
You know, when you're like sitting in a plane for a long time. Oh,
I guess it is.
And so I had to get up and walk because it's about painful.